まさきさー
今財布何円入ってんの？
んふっｗｗｗ　ねええええｗｗｗ
いや普通に気になるんだよね。。。
26,000円。。。
26,000？！
なにぃ？？ｗｗｗなに？？ｗｗ
ねえ、見して！見して！見して！
ねぇｗｗこわいｗｗ
一回見して見して、財布
一般的な大学院生の財布の中の金額を見たいなっていう
絶対なんかあるｗｗ
いや、ないないないないない
あっ！！！！！
ぇえ！！！！！
なんでもない　一回ちょっと…ｗ
えぇ？なにぃ？ほんとにやだぁｗ
ちょっと失礼します
２万…６千……８２円…
まぁまぁだね。
ｗｗｗ　なになになにｗｗｗ
まぁまぁ持ってるね
ピンコン♪（送信音）
いーなぁ…お金……
まさきぃ～～
え？？
コンビニいこぉ～～
なんで？？ｗなんで？？ｗｗｗ
今呼んでっていうＬＩＮＥをしたｗ
してないしてない
ヒュン！（効果音）
なぁーーんでこっ……
ちょ、ちょ、あ、あの、おいとこ、おいといてみよ？ｗｗｗ
おいといてみよ？ｗｗ
大丈夫大丈夫…あの、おいといてみよう？
一回おいといてみよう？
えぇ～……やだぁ……
えーーー、こわいよぉ…
絶対いたずらするなよ。
いやしないよーー（棒読み）
本当なんかあったら法テラス行くからね
ほんと大丈夫大丈夫
ばいばーい
やだよぉ……
テテテーーン（効果音）
（ニヤッ）
何とか気合でターゲットの財布だけを置いてって出かけさせたんですけども
まぁ彼の財布の中には今、
わぁお！
2万6千…えー、82円　入っています
こおおおおおおおおんかいなんですけどもぉ
彼ですね、結構お買い物っていうか、こうなんかスーパーとかよく行くんですよ
全然知らないですけど
めちゃくちゃスーパーとか行くような気がするんで、
たぶん小銭をすごいたくさん使っちゃう
ほら、だからお札ばっかりで小銭が少なかったんですよ
なので今回ですね
ちょっと優しいドッキリというか、彼を幸せにするドッキリです(*^-^*)
もし！！！財布の中のお金が
全て一円玉に両替されていたらドッキリ
いやぁ、、さぞ喜ぶことでしょう
絶対喜ぶ！
だってもう物量的にも増えますし
見た目もよくなりますし
あのお買い物とかもすごい楽になると思うので
すごい喜んでくれると思います
そんな素敵なドッキリを…
やっていくぞい！！ぞい！！！！
うううぅぅ
うわぁぁぁ　　（ドンッ）
はぁはぁはぁ
はい、というわけでさっそくこの財布の中に一円玉が…
26,082枚入れていこうと思います
まず100枚
そもそも財布の中に何枚入るかっていうところがポイントっすね
とりあえずこれで50円
これで100円の量です
1円玉100枚くらいだったら、たぶん全然入ると思うところではある
ｗｈｙ？
あ、全然なんとか入りました
さぁ、どんどん増やしていきますっ
うぇい　うぇい
やばい！！！やばい！！！
もうぱっと見超お金持ち
これはさぞかし喜ぶことでしょう
今200円入ってます
うぇい
やばい、もう入んないか
いやいやまだいける
うぇい
ジャラ　ジャラ　ジャラ
300枚くらいがちょっと限界かもしれないですね
いやでも、ちゃんと両替してあげたいんで
財布からはみでても、とりあえずちゃんと26,082枚の一円玉は、ちゃんと近くに置いておきます
ポンッ（効果音）
うぃ～あ～、ゆ～あ～、おんざくるぅ～
うぃ～あ～！
ダダン（効果音）
ふふっ
26,081円
一円玉にするとこれだけの……これだけの大金になるんだなっていうことを
改めて認識しております
いやほんとにやばいよこれｗｗｗ
あ、で、これ一応ちゃんと26,081枚あります
あの、銀行のほうで両替していただいて
ちゃんと数えてあるので間違いないとおもいます
これでターゲットは絶対喜ぶと思うので、帰りを待ちます……ではっ
こわいよぉ
えっ？えっ？暗い暗い暗い暗い
暗い…………えっ？
えっ？
へっｗへっｗへっへｗｗｗ
なにこれ？ｗｗ
えっ？ｗｗｗ
一円？ｗｗｗｗｗ
なんでこんなことになってんの？！ｗｗ
一円？？ｗ
え、なんで？ｗｗｗ　なに？……これ？ｗｗ
全部両替させていただきました
はっはっはっｗｗ
まじ？ｗｗ
うん……嬉しい？？
嬉しいｗ
ぱっと見、とても悲しんでいるように見えますが、、、
耳を澄ませると
心の声が聞こえてくるのです
ありがとう、はじめん
はい、というわけで、えー
後輩の財布の中身を全部一円玉に両替するドッキリでした
ふっふっふｗｗｗ
持ち帰ってね
いやだよｗｗｗｗ